One of the things that I wish women would.
Would women and people that I think would help with loneliness,
with everything, is people are so obsessed with romantic love,
as if romantic love is the only kind of love there is in this world.
And I think that's why single moms can be such a fucking threat to men.
And that's why single moms get rejected or whatever,
is because we don't need you.
I have all the love in the world that I could ever want or need
with my children. They love me and I love them.
My heart is full and fulfilled everyday because of my children.
I don't need a man to pay my bills.
I can walk through this world
and provide everything that I need for myself.
So if someone's gonna come into my life,
it's because you add something to it.
It's because I actually like you.
It's because there's more happiness in my life with you in it
than without it. And most men can't offer that to women.
And that's why I think people get so.
Women will get so sad and depressed.
But just taking the focus off of romantic love
and looking at all the love you do have in your life,
and even if you don't have that many people in your life,
you should love yourself enough to.
To really feel yourself to be like,
I'm good, I'm good. I don't need to accept
shit like Literal shit like abuse,
like name calling, yelling,
intimidation and aggression.
And pretend that that's love.
Because I just don't wanna look and face myself
and face my inner self and my.
My bits and pieces. Do you know what I mean?
Like it's not romantic. Love isn't the end all,
be all of life. There should be other forms of love in your life
that fill you and fulfill you.
So that you're not so desperate to try to attain this one love.
And it also helps with the feelings of loneliness.
So I hope instead of finding a man,
I hope you find yourself and fall in love with yourself.
Cause that's ultimately
what will get you everything that you want in life.